The question that we have
before us is when
do the divisions between
us and them,
when is that productive?
When is that something
that really helps our
societies?
And in what cases does
it become really problematic
and how can we overcome
those problems and
maybe reconfigure the we
and the them, or
at least see them
not in an antagonistic way,
or a threatening way,
but in a way that's
complimentary,
or that we can live
in co-existence.
That historically the ways
in which states,
and governments,
and societies have tried
to construct these feelings of trust,
and solidarity is by
defining out-groups.
So we build in-group solidarity
by distinguishing ourselves as different from
and better than
others and in today's world that
strategy is just-
it's dangerous, and it's self-defeating.
As a matter of public policy, of concerned
citizens, of people of the world we want to
understand how we can build a more inclusive
and just society.
What CIFAR allows, and I think this is unique
really to CIFAR is it allows a group of people
who share interests to spend some time together
to figure out how to talk to each other, how
to draw links with each other and then...
be able to design some more specific collaborative
research projects.
If we can better understand how to mitigate
the negative consequences of seeing someone
as an other potentially blur the boundaries
between groups, maybe sometimes erase those
boundaries, or recognize that people are different
but that we can still work together in collective
projects to increase the rights and resources
that everybody has I think will make our world
a better place.
[Music]